this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Susan for the introduction and
it's always nice to talk to your
colleague about your work so today today
I'm going to tell some of our very
recent research on crop or nutritional
quality improvement so my lab has been
focused mainly for areas so why is the
carotenoid research and a society
Selenia and the micronutrient
biofortification and today I'm just
going to tell you some of our recent
research results and carotenoid research
so this is a slide I always like to use
to introduce crowd noise so crowd noise
are not new to any of us because the
carotenoid gave their red orange and the
yellow color find that you Melling
vegetables fruits and flowers so why are
we interesting with carotenoid research
this is because carotenoids are known to
be important in human nutrition and
health like in reduce the risk of cancer
heart disease and
age-related eye diseases and it's some
of the carotenoid we called from vitamin
A Croton oil like a beta-carotene
something one or two basic arrays and
they are not to provide the precursor
for what means a census since our humans
can't synthesize the wedding ace so all
the word meaning our diet can be
ultimately traced back to
carotenoid origin and many staple crops
are known to contain very low level of
crowd noise as the results they
contribute to the global prevalence of
vitamin A deficiency and as you can see
vitamin A deficiency effect a large
number of the preschool children and the
pregnant woman
in those two poor areas so quickly crowd
noise say 40 terpenoid compounds they
crowd my advice and safety pathway has
been well well-established over half
century or goes and the many carotenoid
because they double power and the ring
structure give distinctive colors like
we know tomato is red color because
tomato accumulated a lot of lycopene and
the carrot is orange color because
accumulate lots of our accounting and
the beta-carotene many yellow flower
like a daffodil is the yellow color
because accumulated looting and the
others and so fails so during the past
two decades we also start to understand
the process to product to produce April
carotenoids include some plant homas ABA
and Astro collectin and also beta ion
the volatile compounds to give a flower
foods big the flavor and aroma so all
the genes in the carotenoid by synthetic
pathway have been major gene all the
team in the major cotton or by synthetic
pathway have been clone and the whale
study from many crops and planted
species however till now we still have a
very limited knowledge about the
transcription factors and the Richter
genes controls the expression of those
pathway genes so crowd noise essentially
are synthesizing in plastic implants
tissues so carotenoid has synthesized
will be nearly all kind of plastic like
AB no class
chromecast and chloroplasts etcetera but
they accumulated in high levels in
chloroplasts in doing leaf tissues and
also he
chromecast funding many flowers fruits
and vegetables since they out might go
of our
research is to understand how plants can
synthesize a high level of carotenoids
so this is our focus to try to
understand how crowd noise are
synthesized and that regulate in
chloroplasts so for many of you know for
a long time my lab has been work with
the orange gene that was originally
cloned from orange cauliflower and used
the map based cloning strategy we closed
this gene and the fund it's that it does
not encode enzyme involved with
carotenoid by synthetic of pathway but
instead is encode a protein is one on
low function and the contained the
ajaces been reached to me but it's not
chapter on protein by itself because
it's a lack of the jade domains so
recently in collaborator with Israeli
scientists we found that the ort is also
also controls beta-carotene senses
Ameno fruits so our collaborator
collaborator from Israel and the Maeda
crusts between the orange tree Mental
Floss now see with the orange green
mellow fruits tammyjo
and they either f2 population in this
particular population they found the
orange fruit flash segregates with
three-to-one ratio
essentially it's this tree segregates as
a molecule ate the dominant trace so
they did Association analyze and the
fact that they all marching completely
consecrates with the flash color in this
actual mapping population as you can see
with green green flash fruits contain
this pear and orange contain this
so in color in additions they also
server the white genetic collections
they have and they found the ort existed
in to have more tides wise associate
with green flash for from all those
young plant collection and once
associated with the either yellow or
user orange or green or white
so in collaborate in collaboration with
them we clone they all arching from
green green flash and orange flash
fruits and we transform them into plants
as you can see the gene from orange the
G they all arching from orange flash
fruits can introduce can induce crack no
accumulation like the orange cardiology
however they gene from the green flash
fruit can't introduce additional protein
or accumulation just like a whitish
control so we looked at they they see
the cDNA sequence between this two
variety there are six snips and the five
of them cause violence mutation and but
while and cosmesis mutation so
essentially the nature genetic variation
show that the in green flash fruits
contains a gene and bringing the orange
contains a a and with the they change it
was one single amino acid change to
change the Archon II means they are
interesting they orange over so to see
if this slip of this single nucleotide
difference is indeed responsible for the
fruit flash color and they say secret
there
Tiwa chain was neutralized so what we
did is that we changed a G into a in the
green G and we change the a into G in
the orange gene and as you can see the
green gene now can induce paranoia
accumulation and the red genes can't
introduce clubs no accumulating so this
will confirm the effect the indeed this
slip is responsible for the Oh our
function and then we code this sleep
golden slip and we coded to go to sleep
because with this single sleep a change
one amino acid and it can cause beta
carotene accumulation and also changes
of food color and does this go to sleep
responsible for all the mental color
difference at least from those germ
plasma I will collaborate and collect
from our roms their work so the next
question we asked was that this golden
slab also work in Azure plant or our
gene so what we did is that we change
they conserved we did a site of the
director mutagen mice to change they
conserve our journey in this case in our
lab doses origin changed arginine to
helping phenomenally lighting and the
alanine and we also changed nearby our
journey into hustling and the transform
those constructor into plants to look at
the color change and as you can see here
when we author they conserve the
arginine into history they are open up
sis o our gene and they it's cause the
carotenoid its cause the color change in
a roboticist college and the when we
looked at the color change and the fact
that the color is indeed associated with
rotten or increase the carotenoid
accumulation and more importantly if we
look at is a profile and we found that
the beta carotene ratio in the white
color only 15% but this become over
fifty fifty percent during two weeks of
dark incubations and the Uniting we
found the history in substitution in a
crop or in this case and soaking or
arching it's also cause the same effect
lead to high level of carotenoid
accumulation
moreover we found that the history is
not the only amino acid change so to be
effective we showed that the aniline was
replacement taking the ort is also
equally effective to promote to Croton
oil overproduction as you can see that
the the colors capture become dark
orange and it shows a high level
carotenoid accumulation so this
experiment shields shows that both our
heads
Annalee can serve as effective genetic
tools for protein or accumulate for
Croton oil
manipulation so what does this funding
means for crowd improvement and
sometimes when we first cloned the
cauliflower all our genes and the way we
tested its effect to improve crop
nutritional quality and they in
collaborate with the joy so well awake
and we put the calculus of our gene into
potato tubers and they are trusting that
not only induce crowd noise
increase in the fresh plate tuber but
during the storage they stimulate a
continuous accumulation of beta-carotene
as you can see here following five
months of storage the crud no increase
over ten times in some lines and
furthermore in collaborated with Mike
Missouri we also look at the crud no
accumulation during storage of the
squash and as you can see the color
become a darker during storage and it's
also a show shared with we increase the
prot noise so what this means they
actually they significant of the
findings that we know staple crops with
as a I just mentioned staple crops with
low level four beta carotene contributes
to the global prevalence of a vitamin A
deficiency and then we also know that
the beta carotene staple crops it's not
very stable during storage because in
most of the case those beta carotene are
synthesized and the store in amyloplasts
so through this to our our transgene
experimenting in potato tuber and also
the squash experiment we know that they
are arching all the you the squash kits
and the post case they provide some
unique Mackley smooth to improve for
beta carotene senses and also stable
storage during the store do we stay and
beta carotene stability during the
storage so if we can find that the
mechanism maybe we have a way to improve
our staple crop which enhance the beta
carotene level not only for continuing
senses but also stable in storage doing
pasta high post the harvester storage
so I showed you that in orange
cauliflower we know the mutations are
doing to a insertion of that transpose
are elements however in the mental case
the mutation is due to nature of
variation with the single nucleotide
difference so because this is single
nuclear time we prove that the single
nucleotide change to change a specific
amino acid and they just change the
functionality of the or to promote
cotton or accumulation so of many of us
know that genome editing will become the
technology you to use to change our
genome to enhance to change the to
improve economic trace and so we are
waiting for the maturity or advanced of
the technology so we can specifically
replace one or two nucleotide to change
one amino acid to say its effect being
improved for beta carotene accumulation
in staple crops and actually you can
collaborate with the Peter bear the
inventor of doden rice they are not
trying to put our our hiss they are
trying to manipulate the rice or arching
to change the history to change the
arginine into history under saying if it
can help indeed can help improve the
total crop knowing level in Golden Rice
and most importantly saying if it can
help stabilize the beta carotene viewing
poster harvested storage and also we
know that I'm sorry
so we also we know that they're there so
tiananmen search and also looking for
later genetic variation so so through
loss approach we are hoping in future we
can improve the staple crop for beta
carotene
not only through transparent approach of
no we know it's not in good state to do
that but we are we believe we can get
uses some way to improve to create a
functional ally of the ort staple crops
through long through traditional
breeding approach so maybe some of you
already notice that in our experiments
we express the both white - Oh our G and
the mutant of our gene and also possible
and show the stimulant level of gene
expression and also similar level of
protein expression but they showed
dramatic difference induce carotenoid
accumulation as you can see it riposte a
color and they total carotenoid
accumulation
so one question we were asking was how
did they over here so annalee all of
them our mutant differentially regulates
carotenoid accumulation so to answer
this question would we try to ask what
is the function of the Y type of our
gene so to answer this question we did
we were looking for oh I interacting
proteins to find that are interacting
proteins we use the
co-immunoprecipitation in conjunction
with mass spectrum analyze so
essentially we have for our robot ops
these plants express the Oh Y type gene
tact with GFP and the GFP only we
extract a protein from this plant and
mix with speeds and then you look out
they call you mellow preceptor to
protein and the collaboration waist
intact
Tannhauser at our USDF units and the his
lab analyzed those gel pen and
identified
around nineteen proteins that can be
this is a nineteen conserved protein
actually from each each gel and we
identified more than 100 proteins so we
essentially flow multi biological
replicates samples we identifying
nineteen proteins so that as potential
candidates for our interaction proteins
very excitingly we found a psy or fight
honey senses as one of them so what is
psy psy of Python he senses it's the
rate-limiting enzyme in cotton all
Bisons this pathway and it's also the
first enzyme in this specific pathway
there are lots of experiment to show
that manipulation of the psy expression
can have a profound effect on total
carotenoid accumulation and here I show
you some example like a thousand rice
here's the golden rice one and golden
rice too you can see the crowd royal
level quite different actually is there
only difference between golden rice two
and golden with rice why to change the
psy and don't and rice to use high at
active psy from maize and golden rice
one use psy from Daphnia flowers and
also here's the golden corn honor it's
just to express that psy you can see
they claw our seeds color changing from
green to orange color and they are
numerous experiment shoulder you express
any psy from from any plants normally
you can get orange colors
showed like here so to confirm that the
psy is indeed they are interacting
proteins we use we use the three
different approach to confirm that
first through Easter too high for acid
and as you can say not only cauliflower
but I wrote those disorders Elisha who
are like proteins they all interact with
the Psy yeast two-hybrid I see and we
also did a prudent assay to confirm such
interaction as you can see here when you
mix the Psy attack protein with so our
tactic protein you can see they are put
down with gfp and you can detect them
with systemic shield the direct
interaction but not in those negative
become shows and third approach we use
the P IFC and the fergal confirm such
interaction in vivo in plastic this is
the site of crowd noise senses so what
does this interaction means and how does
this interaction
I thought effector psy expression so we
generate the overexpress knife we also
got the lock out and also generates the
double lock out as you can see with
those paradoxes knives they show the
dramatic difference in our protein and a
gene expression and then we look at psy
gene expression as you can see here your
alteration of the expression does not
affect on gene expression then we looked
at the protein level and as this slide
show you with the overexpress of the our
genes cause increased accumulation of or
psy and in the single lock out the the
psy protein level it's very similar we
think that they complement with each
other but in the public-house the psy
protein level was significant
deals and this is showing leave case and
similar units you say they similar
pattern of they change so how does our
effector psy abundance so now we know
with overexpress Pierce while the
disappears we overexpress our reduce
express our and its cost
psy change so how how does our effect a
psy abundance so what we did is the way
introduce the psy gfp-tagged the protein
into white I for our Rob doses and also
you - Oh our background I rubbed up this
plant and then we extract on the protein
and inhibit with HF the protein senses
inhabitants and then looking for the
psy GFP protein level and as you can see
they are our background the term
overweight of the psy was significantly
dramatically deals compared without the
protection of all so in addition our
collaborator Roth Welsh from Germany and
he also looked to say if they increase
the psy a protein level in them active
or not quite often when you optically
the protein can be just a protein level
Africa late but not lesser a means the
active and diamond level so from his
results clearly showed that with
overexpressed oru crease the psy protein
level cause increased and an activity as
you know that psy the key enzyme in the
carotenoid by senses and then they
correlate accumulation of carotenoid was
observed in leave tissues when we have
over expressed our and
dramatically faculae reduced when the
levels reduced so in summary of this
part essentially we showed that both our
and/or like directly interact with the
PS white to act to enhance the psy
protein level and activities through
regulated psy protein stability and
because psy is the key and they crack no
licenses pathway its cost increased
cotton or accumulation and actually this
is the one of the first case demonstrate
a protein can act act as the post
transcriptional regulator upper psy to
regulate cotton oil accumulation so
let's come back to the same question we
tried to answer so how does our mutant
differentially regulate carotenoid
accumulation in both of this case does
the differential regulations through
differentially regulates PS wife oh
there are some other mechanism so to
answer this question and we compared the
our hiss and our interaction with the
psy mr to high as you can say both our
hiss and a white type protein interactor
we see psy and the both of plan also
costs increased the psy protein level in
carrot culture and we also looked again
in collaborator with rock work from
Germany he looked at the psy enzyme
activity from his line with our and we
found there's no difference so which
indicates that the
differentially at induced crowd noise
accumulation it's not doing to the our
Hayes has a high capacity
to increase the psy activity all
increase their biases ethical activities
so previously in our study we showed
that with the o.r mutation in car flow
with the single gene mutation it's cause
they changed from numerous Pro plastic
into one or two large chromecast in the
curtain may occur the influence immerse
themselves of their shoots epidermis
cells similarly our collaborators from
Israel and they also observed a mellow
case if you look under light microscope
and there's one or two large chromecast
per cell liking if you look at the
tomatoes they are you should say all
contain a huge number of chrome plus so
both of them showed that the mutation or
the nature of vibration can induce large
chrome plaster formations so what
happened with a little bit of sizzle
Carly that showed the difference the big
difference with cotton or accumulation
and we look at this is long strands Jen
and Arab doses cally and you can see
there is a plastic campaign some dark
circles that's trust
global and the with the overexpress over
arching the plastic have become a larger
but they can retain the same shape but
to the plastic lobe will become and
darker and with the high electro tents
this is the same as the psy only
expressed we believe carotenoids are
accumulate there but when you look at as
they are his mutation or his mutation
and you can see the plastic shape
changed from those and become their
membranes and structures actually those
memory structure it's a member of member
chrome plaster show exactly same as what
we hope there
in orange curd calculus so those
experiments confirmed shows that the key
for this specific a high level of
carotenoid accumulation is doing to the
unique ability of the overhead you
induce chromecast's biogenesis actually
is this the experiment it's a fairly
significant in a lot of ways we know
arab focuses are excellent the modern
system to understand genes the signaling
in many many process however other arab
doses doesn't contain doesn't contain a
teaching with a chromecast so
essentially we shall here now we
generate arab dopes this nice that has a
program to be able to form chrome
plastic therefore provide as a system to
better start genes and the signaling in
chrome master biogenesis
so here's from our research we showed
that the Oh our mutant has do your
functions in reviews crowd noise
overproduction wise as the post
transcriptional regulators to regulate a
psy and then activity and a larger wise
actually the most important is they have
a unique ability to induce chrome class
the biogenesis and because contrast
provide storage we think that can staple
in storage the crowd noise at the same
time it's also stimulate to continue by
our senses that's why the line scanning
those plants all those lines can can
have a high level of rot no accumulation
fountain we still focused on over
because till now or still is the only
jeans that know to convert convent
chromecast abiogenesis so but the houses
all arching
control complex Genesis is still unknown
so this is a topic and we are focused on
now so in addition to loss research we
also take the advantage of where Islamic
tools to discover genes and proteins
required for high level carotenoid
accumulation so what to experiment we
did is the proteomic analyze complex
proteins in fruits and vegetables as you
can see here we extract Chrome plaster
from some of carotenoid enriched fruits
and the vegetables and we are hoping to
looking for the command mechanism
involved in those crop Marie enriched
crops for Chrome plastic by genesis so
we we we separate the compact protein
from all from from those those
vegetables and the fruits and as one say
interesting we found that if you look at
they're all chromecast the ATP senses
and the ATP ATP translocated are most
abundant proteins in those of Josas 6
chrome chromecast so they hire abundance
of ATP synthesis and the nucleotide
translocator
are just an important role of them in
control or energy production transport
in control chromecast abiogenesis and
the one project is going on their lab is
we trying to figure out if the ATP and
ATP translocator is indeed involved with
complex about Genesis in addition we
also did quite a lot of our thick
experimenting collaborated with many
colleagues on campus and the wonderful
experiment is the bulk second decades on
a sick transcript and analyzed so again
in collaborate with Israeli scientists
we use the same lines to start a our our
gene mellow fruits so what they did is
they groped they the homozygous F 3
family plants and they extracted they I
need from 25 orange or green fruits out
of virus developed fruits developmental
stages and actually here are the army
samples showed there so we popped those
army and did the transcript on analyze
and here's to shoot the crud new
metabolic pathways gene expression
pattern and you know we know you have as
we know that the minnow the orange metal
accumulate a high level for
beta-carotene we found really all the
upstream genes a prickly to do you fruit
development similar as a fruit mature
and they downstream gene down regulates
the in fruit development but a very
interested in is you weren't she fruits
and the carotenoid accumulate but we you
for the Greek food there's no huge crowd
nor accumulation but the gene expression
patterns family which indicate
additional mechanism in this case we
believe the storages think
methanol difference between the green
and orange fruit to distinguish the two
kinds of fruit varieties and the United
in collaborated with jean jean fail at a
pinky I he help us
analyze of those transcript and data and
the in addition he also did the sleep
analyze of the orange and green box and
with this box to essentially be only
alkyl and cut a very low only 64 snips
that with over 90% of rate to
distinguish orange the green box and we
sing those snip only two genes once they
are gene and there's a lot of one
it's totally completely distinguished
100% distinguish between the folks so if
we don't know the ort is responsible for
the orange colors through the Polka
segregate honestok analyze well we would
identify the ort which also showed
effectiveness of the out strategy for
gene discover under they a larger
consecrate came to the gene counselor a
visitor scientist in the lab studies
that gene to say if it also contribute
to the carotenoid accumulation so we
looked at the differential express the
gene at a different fruit development
stage and we found there's only one gene
show the differential express in all
fruits development state but we are
mainly focused on the 20 da to and we
select a few candidate genes best
candidate genes for functional analyze
as I told you they are robotics this
Colossus system we used to start the o
our function and it showed very
responsive and effective to
response the genes that's involved with
scrutton or accumulation and we all know
that they are noticeably flowering
Deeping massive you can't simultaneously
trans
from a lot of genes so this system also
really give us a relative a high
throughput to test those genes and the
proteins identified from other Oh make
take not all mix and the unit ation as I
told you that in many case it's no over
control the orange worse now orange
fruit flash color but we see they ou are
germ plastic collections they are
several Mackley there is the self there
is the several magnitude of variation of
a beta carotene levels so again in
collaborator with these really
scientists we are going to genome type
of those germ past the collection by GPS
and then look at the association between
the mellow fruit beta-carotene content
and the later genetic variation not only
to identify some markers to be useful
mellow mellow breeding but we are hoping
to identify added additional alleles
that control high-level tretinoin
accumulation so in summary our data
shows that say oh our mutant has served
as effective genetic tube for crowd
knowing enhancement in food crops pulses
through traditional breeding and hopes
will post through genetic and the
traditional breeding approach and also
our media beta-carotene overproduction
through regulates both psy with enhanced
by senses ability and also crumb cluster
with the storage abilities and as I just
as I mentioned we believe that if we can
put the crowd noise into chrome plastic
instead of Amla plus we can help to it
can significantly help to stabilize the
beta carotene staple crops
and largest things our data shows that
post-transcriptional regulate of psy he
planned a novel mechanism and the crowd
noise accumulation so finally I like to
say co-op co-workers here's our people
can't leave their lab and especially I
want to thank all England posting their
lab for all the work I described and
also some former lab member for the work
itís described here especially Zhang
Jian's oh and also an undergrad student
Katie ah spring and she did four year
researching their level she's a
co-author of three of our publications
and she was graduate last year mr. hi
stronger and the Hearst honors thesis
research I mentioned briefly and the now
she said MD PhD students you are a very
prestige PhD MD program finally I also
like to thank some of my wonderful
collaborators the Israeli a scientist
and their students and the rap for Menon
work laughs were from Germany from for
our psy work and some qianxi and
shooting them from China for their
plastic work and also some long-term
collaborators on campus for their
contribution for their work I just
mentioned here and the funding from our
research from our usda-ars base from
Bagram and the USDA nifA grant and thank
you for your attention I'll be happy to
answer
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu